never thought I'd say it
but the moment Jeremy Hunt
was announced as the next Chancellor I
said it's a globalist coup and this is
language that previously I'd have looked
at and thought well I'm not going to
touch that I'm not going to go there but
I literally think that
what is the point of the conservative
party Nigel
it's the first time it's ever happened
no they represent nothing absolutely
nothing the conservative party need to
be replaced the new narrative is the
next Industrial Revolution is going to
be Green Technology green energy and of
course it's all for the birds what has
been done in the name of climate change
has led to one of the biggest
transferences of money from the poor to
the rich this country has ever seen in
history Central Bank digital currencies
you know would mean that every payment
into our accounts or out of our accounts
would be monitored would be controlled
the state would have total supervision
of the entire receive of our economic
activity I think everything's broken I
don't think anything works here at all
and I think things are going to get a
lot lot worse
foreign
hey Francis are you worried about
inflation
absolutely mate every time I dare it it
smells me right up there's bloating not
inflation what's the difference neither
is good for you and they both leave you
feeling devalued but absolutely
atrocious if you are worried about
actual inflation and need impartial
advice as to how to survive the economic
crisis than fortune and freedom is for
you fortune and freedom is published by
South Bank investment research and is
for the investor looking to access a
wide range of informed opinions on lots
of different investing opportunities
their brilliant newsletter covers
everything from causes and the impact of
inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through their daily news
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
Fortune freedom.com that's
fortuneandfreedom.com and sign up for a
free newsletter that will help your
money work for you the link is in the
description
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest is returning
for the third time it needs no
introduction whatsoever Nigel farage
welcome back to be back and great to see
how well you're doing thank you so much
Nigel it's good to have you on have you
been first of all good I mean you know
living life outside of leading minor
political parties
funny thing people ask me about it all
time funny thing is this you know what I
do whether it's for GB news or the
business stuff I'm doing if I get it
right people say Well done if I get it
wrong people say you're an idiot that's
fine I'm directly accountable for what I
do leading ukip and the brexit party you
know it's the sort of
mid-saturday morning phone call from the
mail on Sunday did you realize that your
membership secretary in Sheffield at
three o'clock this morning posted a
comment on Twitter and suddenly you're
responsible for everybody else so at the
moment
um being a bit more of a loner than I've
been for many years I'm enjoying it and
you know obviously I've been there with
GB news almost since the beginning but
it's quite an exciting thing to try and
get a new TV channel off the ground in
the UK so I'm happy myself but not
wildly happy about the state the country
is in well quite and uh I mean I can
understand the relief you you'll no
longer have people working for you that
you've never met who are saying you know
gays cause flooding or whatever
but that one was classic
that's God that guy I mean but this
shows you what you're up against yeah
taking on the British establishment that
guy had been a conservative counselor
for 22 years right right and he was a
far and brimstone Methodist Minister and
you know on a whole range of subject
and all the one he was a conservative he
didn't he didn't even make the local
paper
as soon as he becomes ukip it's a
national sensation and that's kind of
what I had to put up with and and you do
realize
uh you know and you guys are doing it
with what you're doing with this podcast
when you take on
perceive wisdom the consensus view of
the day you know you are automatically
written off as being mad and bad the hit
Pieces come out and all the rest of it
but look you talk about the state of the
country which is much more important
than that and I want to take you back to
ancient history Nigel the 44 days of the
trust Premiership because I remember
you know irrespective of the person some
of the stuff that she was saying I
imagine knowing you a little bit would
have had you quite excited I mean low
taxes pro-business fracking
relaxation of ir35 rules which are
killing
you know small self-employed men and
women acting as contractors whether
they're driving lorries or doing working
with tech sector no a lot of it was good
thinking
um you know for example vat free
shopping we're losing this business
we're losing it to Paris we're losing it
to Frankfurt you know lots of little
things there that actually added up and
made an awful lot of sense the most
important thing was a change of
Direction now what quieten's budget did
it proposed a very modest half a percent
cup of the size of a steak that's all it
was half a percent girl in the size of a
state and the globalists went absolutely
mad led by the international monetary
fund who acted I think in the most
extraordinary way and of course we saw
later on pylons from the White House
from the German Chancellor ship
um and yeah 44 days it was all over in
fact she lasted exactly the same time as
Brian Clough lasted at least
and I look I mean I think
here's the funny thing they said these
are unfunded tax cuts and that's the
problem the markets have got and yet a
cap had been put on Energy prices that
could have been Limitless
if the price of natural gas are
continued to go up
so yeah you know we are
I sort of
never thought I'd say it
but the moment Jeremy Hunt
was announced as the next Chancellor
I said it's a globalist coup and this is
language that previously I'd have looked
at and thought well I'm not going to
touch that I'm not going to go there but
I literally think that is what happened
this is what I was going to ask you
Nigel because I think the globalist part
of it we can talk about as well but also
from within the country itself I'm
starting to wonder whether we have
dynamism in this country well with the
belief that like we seem to have become
a country that forgot that's forgotten
that we have to make money before we can
squabble over who gets what like do we
still have that drive and ambition and
the desire to build things in this
country or have we given up look there
are lots of people out there that are
entrepreneurial that are hard working
that despite the tax regime despite the
regulatory regime will still go out
there and do their best
but there's an awful lot of people who
were not doing that because they're not
being encouraged to do that they're not
seeing the reward for doing that I and
and
we kind of got into a situation the
pandemic was a very good example
where both of our political parties are
saying the state will look after you
from the moment of conception until
death the state will look after you and
for a lot of people that's a very
comforting message you know you won't
you know don't worry we'll put you on
furlough don't worry we'll compensate
you for this for that for the other
um
and welfareism
you know welfareism I'm afraid is making
millions of people lazy
you know
I'm too fat I'm too stupid I'm too lazy
I don't get out of bed in the morning I
smoke drugs give me money I like the
fact that he's pointing at me
oh no and that's what we're saying I
don't need to work the state's going to
provide for me
um but this is all running up against
a series of deadlines we just cannot go
up we can't afford it we cannot go out
you get all this Guff from the
conservatives about cutting the cutting
debt you know all they do is cut the
deficit a little bit the deficit still
builds and it's quite a sobering thought
the debt is still builds yeah yeah and
that gets ignored
you know I mean I listen to you you hear
conservative politicians saying things
like oh we are we the conservative party
we don't want to leave debts to Future
Generations we'll have to think about
this when David Cameron stepped to the
door of number 10 our accumulated
national debt since the Napoleonic War
was about 700 billion it's now 2.5
trillion and yes you know I get it we've
had pandemics
Etc
um but every single year the size of a
national debt gets bigger uh you've now
of course got a rising interest rate
environment being you know even the
repayments on debt are more than double
our current defense budget we've got a
National Health Service I'm an amazing
to think that we're now putting 12 of
our GDP into Health 12
just a handful of years ago that was
eight percent so a 50 increase
in the share of the national cake
being put into health and fewer people
getting treatment or seeing GPS so
something's gone fundamentally wrong
with this model and I think that quateng
fully understood that
and Trust May well have been a late
convert to all of this but hey that's
what she stood up and said so now I
welcomed I welcomed much of the budget I
think if there is a criticism they try
to do too much too quickly without prior
briefing an explanation there was an
element of big bang about the way in
which it was done because I remember the
81 budget you know the 81 budget
which is that she was a deeply unpopular
prime minister unemployment was climbing
fast inflation was climbing fast things
were very very tough
and that budget there were 364
economists wrote to the times to say you
know this budget is a disaster
but the difference was Thatcher held
she held her position you know the lady
is not returning that was that year and
81 and the back benches held
and what happened here is the back bench
is wobbled really quite quickly because
a lot of conservative back benches are
basically globalists and listen to those
big noises that come from the
multinationals from IMF Etc
um and as soon as she sat quietly it was
over
quieting was out hunt was in it was all
over I I would much have preferred for
her to hold her nerve
hold a nerve the two of them stay
together keep making those arguments and
see if the party dare get rid of them
but that didn't happen I'm gonna ask you
a quite unfair question Nigel I'm used
to that
what is the point of the conservative
party Nigel
um
told you it was a tough one
I've absolutely know it I'm sorry you've
got me it's the first time it's ever
happened
no I mean look you know they are even
pmqs every week there are back benches
we need more money for this the state
must do more than that the constant
demand and they represent nothing
absolutely nothing I mean here we are
it's quite for me this is fascinating 10
years ago from 2011 onwards it was
pretty obvious we had call me Dave in
number 10 we had
um the man who's driven the Facebook
share price down by 80 the Deputy Prime
Minister I did say to everybody once he
went there sell your stock I've been
saying it again and again and you had
miliband running labor there were three
versions of social democracy and social
democracy is a soft form of Socialism
that says the state can do things better
than you as an individual can do them
for yourselves and at the time you know
my phrase was you can't put a cigarette
paper between them and everyone thinks
that the brexit Insurgency was about
Europe and immigration actually it was
about a whole raft
of issues and it's why it's why ukip was
winning Council seats you know district
county seats on the Welsh assembly
whatever it was that we were questioning
the whole Narrative of where the
national debate was
the point about brexit and I think most
people miss this
after three years of the establishment
doing their best to overturn the result
because that's what they did
when I came back with the brexit party
which which probably my proudest
achievement actually to launch that
thing and it took off like a rocket you
know six weeks we won the election Mrs
May resigned before the count I mean oh
joy I mean these were great days what
was interesting about that was what was
the slogan I Rama
change politics for good
it wasn't even about getting the brexit
deal done it was change politics for
good
and there was a belief and a desire that
the brexit vote this I mean it was a
modern day peasants revolt against the
entirety of the establishment and a
belief that it would lead to a new kind
of politics
hasn't done that in fact the Torres had
been more of a chamocracy
even than they were under Osborne and
Cameron and frankly you know
starmer can talk about the 80 on school
fees on non-dom status but really really
there's nothing to choose between these
parties and if conservatism
does represent
Enterprise hard work reward for success
and a small state then it's dead it's
dead and I
I mean my anger
my anger with Johnson
and the conservatives is all too real
because he wouldn't have even been there
without me
she'd have stayed on as prime minister
you know she couldn't even be challenged
under the party rules
for many you know for quite a long time
many many many many more months and then
in the end you know in that election
of 19 we gave Johnson a free pass on the
basis that we just had to get brexit
finished even if it wasn't going to be
perfect so I'm furious with them uh I
think a very large number of Voters out
there are furious with them
I suspect if there was an election
tomorrow despite the postal voting
register we'd see the lowest turnout
in modern history was aware what's the
bloody point you know
um
so I think
that we've reached a point
where the conservative party need to be
replaced
you know labor and live Dems can merge
and we know we've got that sort of
Social Democrat Center left position uh
but what's on the center right at the
moment it's very very difficult and you
know Richard Tice
is leading reform
um you know which was I mean I actually
changed the name from brexit party to
reform I and I do feel that fundamental
wholesale reform and change updating of
our institutions of our methods our
systems is vital and Rich has made good
progress I mean recent polls had them on
eight nine percent or whatever it is
but you know you're taking on a first
pass the post-electual system with all
the inbuilt advantages that it has
so my my sort of
belief is this
I think labor will win the next election
pretty comfortably
and then we'll get to 2026.
it'll be a couple of years in to labor
people will start to realize they're not
offering any
Solutions whatsoever
we'll continue to see these
disincentives if people set up on their
own still some will
also hit a point where the brexit deal
much of its up renegotiation
uh and if there is going to be a moment
when a political revolution
could be launched
I'm thinking in my head it's about that
time what do you mean by political
revolution Nigel
well with brexit I said I'd cause an
earthquake in British politics I did and
the aftershocks are still being felt no
I mean
if we're going to replace the
conservative party that would be a
full-on political revolution a
completely new political party with a
new political ethos look I'm not saying
that it will happen
but I am saying in response to your
question that it needs to happen don't
you think that what we really need to do
is change first pass to post yes of
course and that's all part of the reform
agenda I mean look you know
I won two European elections two
under PR and yet my one big goal in a
general election in 2015 four million
votes and one seat
I mean you know I can't pretend
not to be pretty bruised by that Nigel
coming back to your point about there
not being a cigarette paper between the
parties one of the things that I I think
you you saw my speech at the Oxford
Union and also when I was on question
time I was quite actually stunned by the
way the discussion around Net Zero
happens in this country because there is
no debate there is no conversation this
is what we must do you know like that
tends to be how people approach that
issue well look even conservatives God's
gone there's no God anymore you've got
to believe in something
so climate change and saving the planet
has almost become a new religion
um you know added to which there are
these terrible stories of Hellfire and
Damnation unless we do uh the right
thing yeah I was at a dinner the other
week with sort of former cabinet
ministers and some very big Global
businesses
and conversation was fascinating about
you know we must get to Net Zero more
quickly
and the huge economic benefit we're
going to get from it this is the new
narrative the new narrative is the next
Industrial Revolution is going to be
Green Technology green energy and of
course it's all for the birds why is
that why'd you say that well what's
wrong with NetZero explain to people
who've never thought about this issue
what is wrong with NetZero number one
let's think about the big picture you
know is carbon dioxide leading to global
warming and catastrophe and the Maldives
disappearing
possibly I have no idea I I absolutely
no idea any more than you do or anyone
does what I do know is that when anybody
tells you the science is settled
that is utterly moronic
but one of the reasons it's so difficult
to get an open debate on this
is when Tony Blair put the broadcasting
act into law in 2001 which set up ofcom
the regulator Etc
one of the areas over which national
broadcasters do not need to provide due
impartiality
is the effect of CO2 on the environment
and climate change and that is why Sky
News can run a whole climate hour
that is why Radio 4 could have
programming all day
that talks about the sheer certainty
that what we are doing is leading to
climate change so that's why we can't
have a debate all right and it really
you know once you understand that you
begin to see why because Blair said the
Sciences settled now
let's go back to that question
even if
CO2 levels
are leading to an excessive warming of
the planet
you have to ask yourself what difference
do we make
and the more you drill into these
figures the more extraordinary it
becomes Indonesia for example has 243
coal-fired power stations that is how
they get their electricity China last
year or as my friend in America says
China
last year built 80. brand new Mega
Coal Fired power stations India of
course again and here's a stat
that knocks them for six
I asked that group around the table the
other week the Great and the good the
best in our society
asked I said guys anybody here got a
clue how much coal
the world will burn in 2023. of course
they all look at you as if you've come
from Mars
Boris told us at cop26 it was the end of
coal remember the end of coal you know
the coal won't be used in the future
well the answer
is eight billion tons
eight billion tons of coal will be
burned
for electricity generation steel making
Etc in the world in 2023 that is a
bigger figure
that has ever been burnt by mankind on
the planet so actually the use of fossil
fuels around the rest of the world is
going up and up and up and we produce
less than one percent of global CO2 so
even if there is a problem we make no
difference to it so why then will we put
upon ourselves an unnecessary Act of
self-harm what is the logic
of closing the red car steel plant
happened in 2015 redcar up on the
Northeast Coast
in a steel town for 150 years the plant
closes two thousand men and women lose
their jobs economic Devastation for that
town but it's okay because the company
that owned the plant announced the next
day the production will be moved to
India
where the steel would get produced under
lower environmental standards oh and
then the Good Ship back to the United
Kingdom so the net effect on carbon
dioxide is actually up so we can we do
this so we can pretend to be green so we
can say we've reduced our CO2 output as
a country by 44 since 1990. hooray
aren't we absolutely marvelous so we
make note no no I'm an environmentalist
I'm an environmentalist I have been all
my life you know I genuinely worry what
we're doing to the oceans Etc I am an
environmentalist but this is a needless
Act of self-harm you know I mean take
Diesel take petrol I mean up to 40 of a
diesel we put in our cars isn't even
refined here it's refined in Russia
and we import it back in and all we've
done under Net Zero we've exported
manufacturing jobs both aluminum
smelter's gone most of our chemical
production gone most of our refining
gone you know steel making gone
this this stuff still gets made but in
different parts of the world and then on
energy where we could be self-sufficient
and we're going to need
we're going to need fossil fuels for the
next three decades at least in some form
you know we will need coal albeit in
small quantities
although when the wind doesn't blow we
might we might start firing up a few
coal-fired power stations so number one
we make no difference number two we're
putting upon ourselves an enormous Act
of self-harm number three what has been
done in the name of climate change has
led to one of the biggest transferences
of money from the poor to the rich this
country has ever seen in history tell us
more about that how what we've done is
we've loaded up people's electricity
bills with subsidies up to 25 of your
electricity bill has been for renewable
obligation certificates Etc which means
basically we give Bill we've given
billions to large Wind Farm companies uh
to Chinese manufacturers of solar panels
of wind turbines it's ordinary folk and
small businesses that have paid the cost
for this it's been going on for over 20
years there's been an absolute
conspiracy of Silence in Westminster
about it and now because of the cost of
living crisis people are beginning to
ask questions about you know what do you
mean I need a heat pump
it's going to cost me Seven Grand to put
a heat pump on the side of my house you
know electric vehicles are very
expensive it's now of course more
expensive to drive an electric car up
the motorway than it is a car on
unleaded
yeah so now questions are being asked
now the new narrative is that actually
this will all make us so much richer and
so much better there'll be so many more
jobs well yeah there are jobs there are
jobs on the wind farms there are jobs in
Green Technology but probably we're
losing three to four jobs in traditional
manufacturing uh as opposed to what
we're gaining in green this is an act of
self-harm it's hurting the poor it's
making no difference to the global
environment whatsoever and yet it is
pursued with a fanaticism by politicians
and a media that don't need to ask the
questions
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousand thousands of pounds
in legal fees the great thing about
expressvpn is that you don't need any
technical skills to set up just like
Francis fire up the app and it's one
button to connect One Tap on a button
was all it needed for my entire life to
disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
Nigel why are we continuing to do this
when the fact is is our economy is in
the knackers yard according to the IMF
we're the only economy major economy
that's not going to grow this year yeah
I mean that's a funny one in a sense
because actually we've grown we've
actually grown more than the other G7
countries since brexit you won't hear
that
um the IMF are taking a very bearish
View
and I think they're right
I think the tax burden and the former
the the the forward projections
of the tax burden are a massive problem
you just think about this you know we're
sitting here now in February
having this chat
in eight weeks time
corporation tax business tax
is going to rise by 30 percent
30 increase in corporation tax who pays
corporation tax the local launderette
small businesses they didn't just jump
multinationals in fact most of them
managed to avoid paying anything so
they've got a 30 increase in corporation
tax you've got a one and a quarter
percent increase in dividend income
which is how most people that run
limited companies pay themselves a total
refusal
to revisit these ir35 rules which
basically means you know say you're
running your own business
you know and and and
so I'm say I'm a part-time driver I'm
doing work for you
I want to give you a bill
and he will pay that bill to me with v80
if I'm VT registered
against what you pay me I'm allowed to
put the allowable costs
of my vehicle against what I'm doing
but the new legislation says
Nigel you
actually earn nearly all of your income
from Constantine therefore you should
actually be on paye and if it's proven
that you weren't generally self-employed
we can come after you for the next seven
years
so employers are saying
all we want are people on paye an awful
lot of people are saying you know what I
can't be bothered I'll retire early I
won't bother so these are just little
examples of of the wrong direction we're
going in
on direct taxes what the IMF have picked
up on is this when the 40p top rate was
established in 1988
that was top rate tax 1.5 million people
in Britain paid top rate tax for the
current proposals 8 million
will be paying 40p or more so what was
considered top rate taxes now actually a
pretty standard tax
for Middle income people so the IMF are
right
to be pessimistic about what about the
way the UK economy is going I suspect it
won't be quite as bad
they think it is because there is still
entrepreneurial Flair but we got the
model all wrong you know the incentives
have completely gone
um Hunt is crushing that
um and and I
I'm seeing people leaving the country
people people are leaving the country
uh it's quite interesting I was looking
at a global map of this yesterday
unsurprisingly people are leaving
Ukraine you know High net worth
individuals are leaving the UK they're
going Dubai is picking up a huge number
of them
and for the smaller younger
entrepreneurs who were not yet High net
worth individuals but want to be they're
going to Lisbon they're going to Milano
there is huge tax competition right
across Europe we have got this
completely and utterly wrong
Nigel the counter argument to that is
you look at the infrastructure in our
country and it's crumbling the NHS
has put as much as it pains me to say is
no longer fit for purpose I think we can
agree
so what do we do then
well we don't stick with the same model
and keep pumping in more money because
it's clearly not working given the
numbers I gave you earlier yeah in this
chat now we need a fundamental rethink
on how we provide Public Services I
think there is a but Nigel rethink is
just a word what do you mean well we
have to examine whether going to an
insurance-based system might give might
give us a better bang for buck this
isn't working
this is not working and
you know far from far from penalizing
people who want to work for private
education or private Health why not
encourage
want to actively encourage people to opt
out of estate systems and leave more for
everybody else
I don't think the current model of the
NHS is going to survive the way that it
is I think there are examples in France
for example of how you know how they do
things which is much more of an
insurance model in terms of how they
think we've got to change it it isn't
working and
and with the population crisis that we
have the massive population explosion
that we have it just isn't going to work
so Nigel whenever anyone it particularly
me Hears A word Insurance model we
instantly think of the United States of
America which to me isn't a good option
either to be brutal I mean Healthcare in
America is very very good provided you
can afford it but Healthcare well even
if you can't afford it you will get
looked after America you know you are
not left to die on the street all right
but
the problem with Healthcare in America
it's damned expensive it's more
expensive than it is here why well
because it's such a litigious Society
that you know any slight misdiagnosis
you can start to sue so I so yeah I get
the point that you're making but I
didn't cite America I cited France I
cited France you were getting much and
if you look across the board
you look at say cancer
heart attack strokes The Big Three
if you look at those I look at the
French
recovery rates and compare them to the
UK's there is no comparison so we need
to learn some lessons so what does a
French model look like well the French
model of course there is some form of
payment you know you book a GP
appointment in France don't turn up well
you get fine yeah there are little
things like that that the French do but
the way that the way the French Health
Providers work with commercial companies
it's a much closer relationship now we
have some of that the problem here of
course is as soon as the word privatize
come you know everyone throws their
hands up in horror
um
what is interesting and they may not do
anything about it but what it is
interesting
is to see the see where the labor party
is now positioning themselves
so Rishi says the NHS is got a few
challenges but it's okay
and we're going to give it more and more
money
and where's treating who's the labor
spokesman is I think quite a bright lad
says this isn't working we need a
fundamental rethink so you know whether
he delivers on that with genuine radical
thinking remains to be seen But the
reversal of positions here we're seeing
in politics I mean look they're all the
same as we said earlier but you've got
labor saying it's broken it isn't
working
you've got labor arguing that they might
cut taxes at some point in the future
and be more pro-business I mean it's all
over the place it's all over the place I
suspect that a labor as I said earlier I
suspect that two years into a labor
government will realize they've got
nothing to offer whatsoever Nigel am I
misremembering or did you briefly
mention this during your pro brexit
campaign I remember you saying something
about an insurance-based model and the
backlash you got I don't remember you
ever saying anything about it again so
you when you talk about Net Zero being
religion I mean the NHS is literally God
himself the NHS was I think that's
changing I think it was a significant
number of people now who are realizing
you know I can't get a GP appointment
you know that's the most basic level
isn't it of the NHS so I think you'll
see the opinion polls there is now a
shift uh yeah I mean I think it was
Nigel Lawson the one that said the back
in the 80s that the NHS was the nearest
thing to an official state religion
that is changing that is changing Net
Zero interestingly is changing because
if you poll the country
significant number of people
there's something it's just a load of
baloney a lot of others who've clicked
that actually
you know this isn't doing them any good
it's going to cost them a fortune and so
I said earlier that change politics for
good the big hope of the brexiteers the
opposite is happening I actually think
Westminster is now more disconnected
from the country on a wider range of
issues than it was in the run-up to the
brexit vote which is why I hope at some
point this political revolution can
happen not sure why is that why are
politicians more disconnected than ever
from the electorate and I agree with you
by the way the influences upon them
you know Westminster is a as just as
Brussels was when I was there these are
very small villages
there are huge influences on the
individuals
and it happens in all sorts of subtle
ways
it's the dinner you're invited to it's
the person you meet at the cocktail
party it's the basic desire of normal
human beings to want to be accepted
want to be accepted when I went to
Brussels
in 99
there were quite a lot labor lost a shed
load of seats
and there were three of us from UK with
quite a lot of new conservative
MEPS elected someone new biz
others had been MPS before and were
retreads as I called them they never
seemed like that but never mind
and the number of them that turned up
saying you know I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that
I'm going to fight against the system
and I know one of them
excuse me I'm one of them Neil Parish
Neil Parish he have tracked a porn
and Parish on day one was sounding like
me
we're gonna fight this and do this and
do that
a couple of years in
this morning as we were walking into the
parliament one day
so you've changed the tune Neil haven't
you
he was the Dairy Farmer before I said I
suppose life is a bit better than
getting up at 4am to milk the cows
really isn't it no no dear boy I've just
become more pragmatic
and the same happens in Westman
it's about being more pragmatic it's
about wanting to be liked by your fellow
group of human beings don't
underestimate that
it's very difficult for people to stand
alone
um they all thought they'd turn me in
Brussels I mean they didn't they didn't
because I was there for a reason and I
knew exactly what it was
so yeah you finish up with everybody
agreeing on virtually everything nobody
wanted to cause a fence in the modern
Work World in which we live a media that
reinforce this is all of that
um a social media
which if you step outside the accepted
boundaries of Twitter maybe musk will
change that but you know it gives you a
hard time
and I suppose really in a word
cavernous because most people in
politics
they're there for a career
more than they're there for what they
can actually achieve uh and it's yeah it
is a total and utter disconnect
whether we can ever break that under the
first pass the post system remains to be
seen
it's it's such a good point because you
look at all the different politicians
and they all have the same background
they all have they all came to it the
same way yeah I remember even back in
the 90s and the 80s labor x-trade unions
ex-miners conservatives you had people
you know former city boys a lot of
people were former military
those people I mean you've got James
Cleveland yeah you've got a couple still
yeah yeah they're they're dying out with
the Oxbridge set
on both front benches
hit the Oxbridge set I mean nearly all
of them do PPE they did he'll do the
same blooming degree
um
the Tories are worse than labor probably
on this but labor aren't that far behind
yeah how much Real World experience is
there on those front benches and the
answer is not very much or Rishi sunak
worked in Goldman Sachs he did the
photocopy
but there isn't much Real World
Experience there
and the social set
a lot of politicians come from it is
incredibly narrow incredibly narrow I
used to joke with you know the camera
and set that they all went to the same
school all went to the same University
all did the same degree all spent the
weeks in London the weekends in
Westminster none of them have any
hobbies no Hobbies
no Hobbies no interest no no no intro no
Dennis Healey said politicians did a
hinterland you know Ken Clark had his
Jazz and his love for sport you know
these guys have nothing outside they're
working lives at all they marry each
other's sisters I mean it really is it
is true yeah extraordinary no Hobbies I
find that really interesting
they have no passions quite suspects
really in a way well I think so yeah
it's a strange system isn't it I've been
thinking about this quite a lot because
we elect people to run things to run the
country who've never run anything else
there's quite a strange way of doing it
I mean John Reed for example a very
capable man in many ways but John Reed
held eight top cabinet positions for
Tony Blair in 10 years
I mean you've literally barely got time
to get your feet under attack I mean hey
we had five education secretaries last
year
five education secretaries
you know four chancellors
the whole thing is absolutely if you
tried to run a company like that the
company would be bankrupt before you
know it you couldn't write it either you
couldn't run it like that I mean the
argument is that you could argue that
Gordon Brown was thinking this way
because he did bring other people in
like Digby Jones who'd been boss of a
CBI and brown was thinking about
bringing talents in and in America
they brought people in to run
departments who were experts in their
fields and I think maybe a bit more of
that but we we kind of think that
to be in cabinet you have to be an
elected MP and I think maybe we need to
try maybe that thinking needs to change
I think a lot of our thinking needs to
change
you say that again because
there needs to be a Tipping Point Nigel
for all of these changes that you've
just talked about well
so
he's retired now from public life but I
remember having a couple of
conversations with Lord tebet
about all of this remember 1970s we were
the sick man of Europe the country was
going down the drain in every regard
it's kind of why we joined the common
market
we were doing so badly we'd lost the
confidence that we could do these things
for ourselves
and you had half a dozen big Trade union
leaders that ran the country
you know the Lights Went Out the Lights
Went Out
Heath
called an election on who governs
Britain and the people said not you mate
the unions I mean pretty much
there were also suspicions that leading
Union Figures were pretty much hand in
glove with the Kremlin
which subsequently turned out to be true
doesn't surprise me believe me don't
have to be true
but in 19789 the winter discontent
things got so bad
that there was a chance for a new
radical agenda to try and reform that to
get the relationship right between the
employer the employee and that
probably more than any other Factor
led to the great economic growth and
success the country enjoyed from the
mid-80s
onwards
things sometimes have to get worse
before they can get better and I I'm a
Brokenness
I think everything's broken I don't
think anything works here at all
and I think things are going to get a
lot lot worse in terms of public trust
and confidence in the system in the
institutions as they are so I do as you
know and I've hinted a couple of times
today in our conversation I I you know
I'm looking at a could be short it could
be longer but I'm looking at a sort of a
three-year
framework in which in which thinking
starts to change you know really across
the board I've noticed something
interesting Nigella it's not just in the
UK but more broadly I think a lot of us
who've spent quite a lot of time pushing
back or complaining or saying this is
wrong or woke people are this or this is
going on wrong with our culture a lot of
people are now starting to ask the
question of what is our positive Vision
what is what are we offering people you
know what you know I know a lot about
this because contrary to popular myth
the ukip Revolt wasn't a protest Folk
ukip was not just angry pensioners but
that but that's how that's how the BBC
wanted to portray yeah
actually when he polled ukip voters they
voted because they agreed with the
Positive policy Solutions
you know such as leaving the European
Union getting back the ability to make
our own laws run our own country on
borders
you know not having an open door to
parts of Europe but actually having a
global approach you know with a proper
point system sadly what that's meant is
they've lowered all the standards so
virtually anyone can come now
um so no you're right we have to offer
positive alternative Visions I mean
number one is how we deal with the
disconnect between Westminster and the
country and I think a change in the
voting system starts to do that number
two the House of Lords is an Abomination
full of absolute blooming nobody's who
sit there for the liberal Democrats I
mean God Knows Why they've got 104
members of the House of Lords and this
is the upper chamber I mean listen to
their debates
they're even more out of touch
on these issues with the center of
gravity of the country and the House of
Commons is so an updating of our
institutions to get different voices
heard and and a different influence
there is at least a beginning of the
process you have to change the national
debate you have to change the national
media debate as well with it before you
will start to move on I think that's
really really important
and philosophically
case for us to make
and this won't be easy
but the case for us to make
is that the individual matters that
we're not just all part of some great
big Collective
the state somehow owns US
I mean Boris Johnson telling us oh it's
okay this year you can have Christmas
with your family well
I won't say what I was going to say you
know
how's it his freedom
decision to decide what I can or can't
do so I think there is something here
around the individual yes yeah that we
are people we choose our units whether
it's Partners wives husbands families
communities churches whatever we choose
but but kind of we're being looked upon
it's as if that relationship between the
governors and the government
has been reversed it's the pay it's the
price you pay for welfarism because if
I'm paying for you then I get to tell
you what to do that's exactly right and
that now extends you know all the way
through
people may say it doesn't matter but
anpr you know and one that I'm very
heavily involved with with and as you
know I you know I do stuff
on the financial services side as well
trying to help ordinary folk understand
what's going on
last week the treasury
were advertising jobs
to work in a central bank digital
currency Department
do not underestimate this
because we don't know anything about it
what is it why are you concerned about
it we know digital currencies exist we
know you've got Bitcoin ethereum and
thousands of others and they're
incredibly volatile and some people have
made millions and some have lost their
shirts and we've had big bankruptcies
but these things still exist
a central bank digital currency would
mean a cashless Society
we would not carry any cash now actually
the pandemic was used
to try and stop us using cash I agree in
many many cases unless of course you
visit a so-called Turkish Barbers but
that's another story
where is cash only still yeah
Central Bank digital currencies you know
would mean that every payment into our
accounts or out of our accounts
would be monitored would be controlled
the state would have total supervision
of the entirety of our economic activity
now people will say isn't that what
happens already though uh no because you
can still spend things on cash the rest
you know I mean they are not completely
in control of Our Lives now they are far
too much yes I'd agree with you
why should we be why should I as a
law-abiding citizen be fearful of
government knowing every single
financial transaction that I do
because after all if I'm law abiding
I've nothing to fear
unless of course
you live in Canada
and you're a trucker
and unless you've had about 14
coronavirus jobs
at least one of fortnight that's what
Tony Blair wants for us by the way do
you see that the other day yes I did
yeah Tony Blair Sega all the Jabs to
come well I mean I feel like a YouTuber
in caricature
um
and these people were having their
rights to right to work
taken away from them for no good medical
reason and they staged the truckers
protest in Canada
what happened to them
government put pressure their bank
accounts were closed and Frozen
under Central Bank digital currencies
they could have flip to switch
I've done it you are giving you are
giving government total control over
your life and you know we've learned
just this weekend
that Brigade 77
counterintelligence Army group weren't
even working with the security services
working with the dcms
I mean unbelievable
that these Muppet government ministers
actually had people spying
on journalists political figures
commentators who did not accept that
lockdown was good for you who questioned
the model the professor Ferguson when he
wasn't running his girlfriend's flat you
know it was was putting out to us so
that's the reason why we should fear
Central Bank digital currencies are the
ultimate form of very very big
government and we are beginning to move
in that direction and I that is
something that needs to be fought and
fought very very hard and it's why
actually
I believe
and you can read the ft and you can
listen to all the establishment
media all of them will tell you that
cryptocurrencies are a scam I can't a
Ponzi scheme I promise you one thing
they are here to stay and if we move
towards cbdc's
I I'll try and do as much of my
transactions buying and selling cars
whatever it is I'll try and do it on
crypto
so you've
that's
you see that's the reason we haven't
looked into it Nigel because we saw the
way things shifted during the pandemic I
saw the way they subtly tried to
eliminate cash and then there's now
about Brands like protamon J simply
don't accept cash
do you think look and it's gonna sound
like a conspiracy theorist do you think
that these there's no conspiracy theory
I'm telling you what's happening
I'm telling you exactly what's happening
a hundred governments around the world
have an open debate about whether CBD
sees the way forward that's where we're
going
how do you see it being implemented do
you see it being implemented in 5 10 15
years oh it's obviously obviously take
time to do something like this but it
tells you everything you need to know
about our political class about the
media class that back them up about the
whole philosophical debate that the
three of us are having sitting here
today you know we're saying something's
gone wrong with our politics I think the
fact there is no outcry
about those treasury adverts last week
no questions in Parliament no one
debating this shows you just how badly
wrong these things have gone I you know
I do not get him I'm a pragmatist I'm a
former businessman that got involved in
politics uh I haven't got time for
ranting conspiracy theories I do believe
in asking questions but but these These
are the directions that the West is
going in increased welfarism increase
tax reduction of choice infringement on
free speech and ultimately total control
of Our Lives well you mentioned total
control Nigel and Francis mentions
conspiracies and one of the big things
that a lot of people are now talking
about is Davos Klaus Schwab globalism
um
and to some people it's a you know some
kind of cabal of pedo lizards whatever
is the craziest yeah
no sorry
and there are other people much more
reasonable I think who go look this is a
an assembly of powerful people who have
a particular vision and and their
religion is clearly climate alarmism
that's what they're about that's the
number one thing yeah now for now that's
what they stand for and of course it's a
global problem which requires
Global Solution One Center of power blah
blah blah blah forget National
sovereignty Etc yeah
so
and and then you see you mentioned Tony
Blair you know we need to track
everyone's vaccine status everywhere at
all times forever for the rest of
Eternity what do you make is that
is that in by globalist when you use
that term is that the people or who are
these globalists and what are they what
are they up to it's a mistake to think
that cloud Schwab is the man stroking
the white cat you know who is the evil
genius I mean he looks like a blowfish
it just needs a skull yeah no I mean
look
I hate you know we've had the Bilderberg
Group we've got the wef uh I spent over
20 years working in Brussels which is
the epicenter
of the globalist project
and it's that coming together
of
big government
big business
big Banks and now big Tech
it it is the common shared interest of
all of those people it is that it is and
you say climate change is their
motivation and their real motivation is
money
money and control power and control
and
you know the truth of it is
the more you have
globalized standards
the less opportunity there is for the
individual and I'm back to that word
again because I think is very important
to design new products to come into a
market to be a market Challenger
you know it's why you finish up I mean
frankly
if I'm Deutsche Bank or Goldman Sachs I
want the city of London to be as
regulated as possible
I want more and more and more law
and I loved it in Europe because I could
just brief the bloke at the European
commission and he'd write the
legislation and maybe in the parliament
understood it anyway and the more
regulation there is
in a business environment the more costs
there are legal costs compliance costs
Etc
the barriers to entry
for new ideas and new participants are
such that no one can and I mean
America's got this problem
you can go
to shopping malls in any of the states
and see exactly the same shops yes
absolutely no challenges no small
businesses
so
I would argue that's the way the world's
going you can't do anything about it
um I don't agree with that
I think of course we value international
trade and global trade and all these
things
but I think
for me
one of the opportunities of brexit real
options as a brexit was for us to have
the opportunity to become so much more
entrepreneurial
than the rest of Europe and that means
getting rid of some of those barriers
now because since you're trying to do
that oh he wants to change employment
legislation it's a return to slavery or
you know okay well no but that's that's
that's that's that that's how the
counter argument gets put
um so look we can't lay it all at the
door
of Klaus Schwab although interesting
isn't it Mr Blair clearly wants that job
I mean that was a pitch for that job but
that is what we're up against and you
know you asked earlier
about
how Westminster has become so detached
because these are the influences on them
and Nigel
you would know more than anyone about
the European Union and I'm looking at
the European Union I'm I voted to remain
but I look at the European Union as a
project long term and I think it's
doomed economically I think the euro is
is a ridiculous idea it's a utopian idea
the whole thing seems to me like a
utopian project
all the southern European States seem
like zombie Nations and Perpetual
recession
so sad what you know what's happened to
the Greek people what's happened to the
Italian people it's very sad
so what is the future for the EU what do
you think will happen in five ten years
or and long term as well well I mean you
know all the all the EU is really is an
updated form of Communism that uses big
businesses as as as as their friends you
know they accept the state can't do
everything they need to have commercial
actors that operate with them to do this
um look it will not survive but it is an
enormously powerful institution it's
it's its grip
it's grip it's over over the levers of
politics and media of
big Tech which we just can't ignore any
of this these days
um
it's huge
and
any politician that dares to stand up
and say we should leave it he's in for a
very unhappy life
around Europe Maloney all the others you
know that they'll talk about changing
direction about slowing down the speed
of integration but no one dares to
actually take them off
um I did it uh cool must be mad no but
look ultimately in the end it isn't
going to work it isn't going to work in
the end
it'll be the economics that unravels it
in the end
it'll be Italy
that just says you know what we cannot
put up we're getting poorer and poorer
and poorer every year we cannot go on
being stuck in a German dominated
currency as to how as to when
that happens I can't tell you but it
won't survive you know when you were
talking about increasing regulation and
raising the barriers to entry one of the
things that shows the reverse of that is
what's happened with the media if you
think about this this is the exact you
know 10 years ago if you wanted to start
some kind of media organization you
needed a million quid right now you need
two cameras and a couple of microphones
uh so I suppose as long as big Tech can
be kept within line well that's all well
and good yeah that's all well and you've
had a big recent hit from the Oxford
Union and well done you that's what I
had in 2010 with Hermann van rumpy pumpy
rum boy
but here's the thing
my political career
would never have taken the ukip Beyond
being
you know a minor party
I'd never have got Beyond minor party
status without YouTube
would never have happened
never happened a lot of cat's chance in
hell you know how could I reach that no
you know if the BBC won't put you on the
news
how can you reach that number of people
and what happened with me was sort of
2008 onwards YouTube was there
[Music]
um
I remember that ghastly man gave a
hofstadt in the European Parliament
standing up once again Mr farage he
comes here he's not speaking to us he's
speaking to a YouTube audience and said
yep it's a fair cop guy
and Trump's the same
for Trump
the tool of choice was Twitter
through which he absolutely dominated
the national and international
conversation
and so what happened was mainstream
media reflected what I did an even
bigger way reflected what Trump did
that was all well and good and to the
creators
of this new Innovative technology
suddenly realize the consequences of
what it is that they created namely that
the peasants
could actually have a say against their
mates in the capital cities and that's
why we saw that period
of
that period of people being banned and
and Shadow banned and counter band and
sometimes by the way justifiably you
know there are things that I've said
that are outright vile or insightful
that I that are not
within the Realms of what's acceptable
as Free Speech but an awful lot of stuff
that got Shadow banned was perfectly
fair and reasonable comment I mean
Facebook for me
um if people like and try and share my
Facebook stuff they get suspended
it's happened again and again and again
so my stuff they'll take just
and anyone tries to propagate my stuff
they stop from doing it you know
suspended for 48 hours or whatever it is
so we've seen the growth of getter or
one or two other new challenges to the
market we've now got obviously Elon Musk
has come in with Twitter
um who was playing he was playing
anaeroic role so yes provided
provided there's enough free space in
Tech your point holds but there are
dangers well we've got to it's an
opportunity to change the culture and I
think that's where all this other
Revolution that you talk about comes in
Nigel we've talked we've we've mapped
out a lot of problems I think and also
some of the solutions too and I think
this message about the sanctity of the
individual the importance of you know
people having the opportunity to start a
business and not be taxed massive and
whatever that's all very important but
let's say by some magical transformation
the country was different and you were
prime minister what would you do what
would be your top five priorities
we'll have a dream to celebrate
obviously
oh I think we have to trial we have to
try and restore
some faith and trust in politics
and stop lying to people Richie soonack
sent an email out last night to
conservative party members on the third
anniversary of the day we left the
European Union so we've got brexit done
number one we've taken back control of
our borders but that is just a lie
correct but just outright lie
so number one you've got to restore some
Trust
and you can only do that by just being a
bit frankly with people it's the number
one be a bit more Frank with people you
know we got this right we got this wrong
hey you know what it's life we're doing
our best I think so I think restoring
trying to restore some faith
and that connection that belief that
you're elected
on a set of proposals and you're going
to do your damnedest to try and keep the
promises that you made that that's the
first thing you've absolutely got to do
the second thing that you've got to do
is you absolutely have to find a way
where people can get GP appointments
it's so fundamental every age it's so
fundamental so you need a very very
rapid thought process as as to how we
can do that
um now longer term obviously one of the
big problems we have is not trading
enough of our own people and relying on
immigrant labor the whole time at Short
Term we're doctors we we may need to
take more from the rest of the world to
try and solve this problem but that
again will be part of restoring that
trust number three fundamental look at
the tax system you know you go back
through the history of mankind you can
find many of the good periods and bad
periods many of the periods of War
peace have actually been caused by taxes
being injudicious or being well thought
through and I think I think in fact you
know restoring some form of incentive to
people I think it's really really
important reducing the tax burden the
fourth thing is her people won't like
this very much but um
we can't go on paying you more to sit at
home
claiming a whole range of benefits uh
that we can you go to work and I'm
afraid
that welfare is going to have to be cut
now that of course you know can you
imagine the protests I mean but I'm
afraid we got to grasp that nettle that
ultimately welfareism is making people
sicker it isn't making them better in
very very large numbers uh and that's an
incredibly hard thing to do
incredibly hard thing to do it's it's
it's as hard
as what Thatcher had to face in 79.
it's as hard as that and number five I
mean you've asked me this off the cuff
but number five
I think in a very uncertain world
I think a really good thing about our
military forces that there are some
great threats out there in the world you
know China Russia things we don't know
about and I think the extent to which we
run down our national
uh defenses in this country over the
course of the last 12 years is utterly
shameful we live in a very uncertain
world look at the things that have
happened just just in the last five
years things that have happened
um so there you go
Nigel as always an absolute pleasure
thank you so much uh the final question
that we always end our interviews with
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
the brain dread is happening for the
first time since 1978 79 young
entrepreneurial good people are leaving
the country in large numbers they're
going
the night the the official figures will
track how many high net worth
individuals they can how many
billionaires leave what you can't
measure are the number of 31 year olds
who've got Tech businesses
who
are really worried about the tax and
Regulatory burden
and who say when they pay their tax look
where it's going it's not helping
anybody they go into Portugal in big
numbers they're going to Milan in
sizable numbers they get to Australia as
they've always done we are losing
once again some of our brightest and
best people and nobody wants to
acknowledge it or even comment on it
it's happening it needs to be stopped
Nigel farage thank you so much we've got
a couple of questions that our audience
have submitted that only they will get
to see in a second but for now thank you
and thank you for watching and listening
we'll be back very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or I'll
show all of them go out at 7 pm UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's always
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
labor government seems inevitable as
you've already alluded to where do you
think they will take the relationship
with the EU
[Music]